Superman is arguably the world's most
popular comic book character since his
creation in 1933 the superhero icon has
went on to influence countless others
and over the decades he has appeared in
all forms of media from movies to games
television and more there is however a
darker side to the character and
throughout this video I will be
discussing all of the real-life
tragedies that have surrounded Superman
ever since his creation with that out
the way
I'm definition and this is my breakdown
of the Superman curse Jerry Siegel and
Joe Shuster whilst Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster are now recognized as the
creators of Superman this wasn't always
the case despite coming up with the
concept of a hero and his mild-mannered
alter ego do you oh sold the rights to
the character for a hundred and thirty
dollars early on in their careers
because of this they were enabled to
bask in the welfare he garnered
penniless and out of work due to the
court battles that spanned decades the
two lived on the breadline and didn't
receive any profit for a long time
practically forced to sign all
exclusivity over to DC they were
informed after the initial deal that DC
already owned the rights to Superman and
should they disagree that their
contracts would be terminated fearing
for work
they of course signed more paperwork
that eventually tangled them in so much
red tape it was difficult to escape from
another way that DC screwed over the
pair was that they rejected their idea
of Superboy comic and then went on to
publish them when the duo was serving in
World War two they also removed their
names as creators in all publications
until decades later and even now have
used their lawyers to assure that the
families of the two received very little
both sadly passed away in the 90s and
never got the Justice that they deserved
George Reeves grieves not to be confused
with Christopher played Superman in the
1951 film Superman and the mole men and
went on to perform as him in the ensuing
television series Adventures of Superman
due to typecasting at the time Reeve
struggled to find work upon leaving the
role and because of this dealt with
heavy debt on June 16th 1959 at days
before he was to be married Reeves was
found dead of an apparent self-inflicted
gunshot wound at the time the death was
ruled as a suicide but controversy
quickly followed due to the fact that
Reeves had been having an affair with
the wife of an MGM executive and his
fingerprints were never found
on the weapon Superman the movie
Superman the movie has by far the most
common occurrences of the curse and
there are several that substantiate its
existence such as Lee Quigley who played
Superman as a baby in the 1978 film and
died in 1991 at the age of fourteen
because of solvent abuse Marlon Brando
who played jor-el
who is part of the curse for the
misfortune that he suffered in his
private life his son Christian shot his
half-sisters boyfriend and was
imprisoned because of this and Brando
himself cite his reclusiveness as being
the cause of his daughter's 1995 suicide
Margot Kidder who played Superman's love
interest had bipolar disorder and in
April 1996 she went missing for several
days and was found by police in a
paranoid and delusional State Kenner
suffered from alcoholism and found it
difficult to gain work after playing the
part of the plucky reporter Christopher
Reeve when you think of Superman you
think of Christopher Reeve and if you
like me then the actor was an icon of
your childhood however this was a
detriment and like several of the actors
before him Reeves struggled to find work
outside of the part
unfortunately in 1995 when horse riding
the actor was thrown from his steed and
became paralyzed from the neck down
Reeve died on October 10 2004 of heart
failure which was cited as stemming from
his medical condition though tragic
grief should be commended for the
charitable work and awareness that he
raised for paralysis and he definitely
became a positive role model for all
those who live with a disability Zack
Snyder known for directing Man of Steel
and Batman V Superman Snyder was part of
the Lakers rebuttal
zatia of the character on screen
Snyder's work was divisive but
personally I enjoyed his portrayal of
the character and found his work to be
stylistically in line with the comic
books of the new 52 era unfortunately
tragedy struck when the creator was
working on Justice League and the
director had to depart from reshoots to
be with his family after his daughter
autumn sadly commits suicide it is
unlikely that Snyder will return to work
on the DC Universe that he began
building and he has asked for privacy
during this heartbreaking period
aliceandmac the most recent example of
the curse aliceandmac has hit headlines
due to her involvement in the cult
nexium Mack is known for her portrayal
of Chloe in the Superman centric show
Smallville since leaving the role Mac
struggled to find work and this saw her
being drafted by the cult leader painted
out as a key figure in the sect Mac was
recently arrested by the FBI and charged
with sex trafficking sex trafficking
conspiracy and forced labor conspiracy
according to prosecutors after she
recruited women to join the organization
she used tactics such as blackmail to
force them into engaging in sexual
activity with the cults leader in which
she was allegedly paid if convicted of
all charges Mac and the cult leader
could be imprisoned for a minimum of 15
years and this is by far the most
shocking thing to come from the legacy
of the Man of Steel so what do you think
of the curse of Superman
do you believe its existence or do you
think that all of the tragedy that
surrounds the character is merely
coincidence comment below and let me
know and if you can think of any other
examples of the curse except for the
terrible mustache in Justice League be
sure to leave your thoughts if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel as I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film thanks very
much for taking the time to watch this
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]